[Musique]
ou les croise au bord des routes au
détour d'un virage comme s'il veillait
sur notre quotidien mais qui les
regardent encore
les poilus à la fois familiers et
oubliés
Roger gloriot fait partie des anciens
combattants très attachés à son monument
aux morts celui de la crise émis joue
tout juste inscrit au titre des
Monuments Historiques 100 ans après sa
construction je pense que c'est légitime
parce que enfin on est toujours un peu
chauffage mais pour les gens de la
commune c'est le plus beau monument du
coin ce qui les importe beaucoup c'est
l'emplacement et surplombe
depuis 2012 l'état effectué un
recensement des monuments aux morts les
plus remarquables parfois c'est
l'originalité de la sculpture comme ici
à Frasnes qui tape dans l'oeil des
spécialistes ailleurs ce sont les
matériaux utilisés
à Pontarlier c'est l'architecture ronde
et accueillante de l'ensemble qui
justifie le classement
à sombakur le monument aux morts est
adossé un chemin de croix un mélange des
genres assez rare
c'est cette alliance entre un monument
dont l'origine et la municipalité la
mairie comme dans toutes les communes
après la guerre de 14 et puis donc
l'alliance entre la République et puis
la religion cette année 19 monuments aux
morts ont été classés en Franche-Comté
dont celui de Salins-les-Bains et que
dire du plus discret d'entre tous celui
d'Oran caché sous les arbres comme
effacé au pays de Gustave Courbet